Have you done it before?
You know, you don't have to wait for
anything. Take it. Take take it.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran. Gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your makyama that you read it
wherever you was. Alhamdulillah,
brothers and sisters, when you go to
Omra Hajj, it is an invitation from
Allah subhana wa tala. And Allahh
invited the whole Salah Pro team to head
out there to meet Shah Faruk Siko and
the rest of the team. Little did we know
Allah subhanaa tala was also inviting
this dear sister who was working at the
checkout for the airlines that Allah was
going to make us the means of coming to
Islam. Brothers and sisters we were on
our way to the airport. Alhamdulillah.
As we went there I forgot myam in the
taxi. Subhan Allah. And that was going
to be chaotic. So subhan Allah we
managed to get in contact with the taxi
driver. I ran back to the the cab.
Alhamdulillah the driver was a Muslim.
He came back without theam. It would
have mean if I would have gone past the
and in Jeda I would have to go all the
way back to Medina. Alhamdulillah the
driver came back. I got myam and I was
in panic when I opened the my suitcase
and I was like where's myam? And I was
ringing my wife. Subhan Allah. And she
said no it's not in the house but
anyways we sort it out. Little did we
know we was in the cube and subhan allah
there was someone that was going to go
before us and said you know if you want
you can go front of us in the cube. It
changed the whole thing that we went to
the kiosk of the sister who was there.
And the reason why I am relaying this to
you before you go, we go to the audio.
Uh inshallah, listen to it because we
lost the audio files and you can barely
hear it. We're going to subtitle
inshallah. But she said that subhan
Allah, she's been fasting in Ramadan.
When she would mention the prophet's
name, she would say sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. And she was like, subhan
Allah, she believed in everything. She
believed in the Quran. We gave a dawa.
We're going to show you the discussion
how it went with subtitles and hopefully
you can hear it. She took her shahada
there and then with us and we said we
want to give you a gift. And we had the
guided prayer mats in our suitcases and
before we can give it she was like you
know what I think one of my friends gave
me one of these and we was like this
exact one. She was like yes. But she
wasn't sure if she still has it. So we
gifted her another one thanks to your
amazing donations. But this is her
journey. May Allah subhanaa tala bless
and preserve her inshallah. Enjoy the
video with what little is left of it.
Inshallah brothers and sisters and make
dua for the sister. Subhan Allah. There
are so many non-Muslims fasting Ramadan
even as a non-Muslim. She took a shahada
in the airport. First time for me. Enjoy
it.
Have you done it before?
You know, you don't have to wait for
anything. Take it. Take take it.
No. No. You can always take your shahada
and
take at least one.
To watch the full discussion guys, just
click the link here or in the
description box. Inshallah. This will
take you to my new DA channel, Ali Dawa
Raw, where from now on all my DA
discussions will be aired. Go now and
subscribe now and enjoy this video in
that
channel. I hunt to life with better cat
too.